[موسيقى]
في منطقه حميد الغزلان جنوب المغرب
لعبوا هوكي حفاه يتنافسون على ارض ترابيه
فريقان غالبا ما يرتديان اللونين الابيض
والازرق وجمهور غفير جاء من كل صوب
للاستمتاع والتشجيع
المباراه باطلاق شيخ القبيله او الحكم
صافره البدايه الركض واللعب فوق الرمال
متعه لا يعرفها سوى هؤلاء اللاعبين
اوكي الصحراء في منطقه محاميد الغزلان
لعبه تراثيه وشعبيه منحدره من تاريخ البدو
في هذه المنطقه يطلق عليها اهل المنطقه
المكشاح او هوكي البدو وتنطلق ضمن
مهرجانات بدويه يحرص على حضورها شيوخ
القبائل والسائحون من كل مكان
منطقه معروفه
من النقط البارزه في المغرب ان كل سائح
المغرب خصو يشوف الصحراء
مراكش وصويره
تدخل ايضا ضمن فعاليات مهرجان شعبي عريق
تنفرد بتنظيمه منطقه حميد الغزلان ان وجهه
الشهيره لاستضافه مهرجان البدو الروحاني
الدولي وهو مهرجان يعيد احياء ثقافتهم
المهدده بالانتظار ويتضمن ايضا حفلات
موسيقيه وعروضا وندوات ومسابقات متنوعه
[موسيقى]
اكبر ان ننفتح العالم العربي خاصه وثقافه
البدويه لنقتسم اختلافاتنا وايضا لنحتفل
بما نتشابه فيه
المتعه احيانا تتجلى ببساطه ادواتها وهذا
ينطبق حرفيا على لعبه فوكس الصحراء رياضه
وحماس وتنافس في بيئه صحراويه بسيطه لكن
وللاسف بعض تلك العادات بدات بالاندثار
لاسيما في المجتمع الصحراوي البدوي فمع
تسارع الزمني توجه كثير من هذا المجتمع
الى الحياه المدنيه ما جعل القائمين على
مثل هذه المهرجانات والمسابقات يبذلون
جهودا مضاعفه لضمان استمراريتها
[موسيقى]